مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
على مدار الاسبوع الماضي كان في حديث وجدر
كبير حول تصريحات جوردن هندرسون اللي قال
فيها العلماء انتقلت على السعوديه من اجل
المال على الاتفاق يقصد
وكان في اسباب اخرى والارقام اللي الناس
دولتها عن انه ممكن اخذ راتب يوصل لسبع
مئه الف دولار بالاسبوع وما الى ذلك هاي
ارقام غير صحيحه وانا اتقاضى اموال جيده
ولكن مش لهالدرجه يعني هاي التصريحات عملت
جدل كبير على مدار الاسبوع الماضي وكان في
حديث واخذوا رد حول الموضوع طب هل فعلا
لاعبين لبعض ينتقلوا على السعوديه وهل
فعلا جوردن هندرسون بالتحديد انتقل الى
السعوديه بس من اجل المال خلينا نتفق على
نقطه اولى ورئيسيه قبل ما نبدا حديثنا انه
المال عامل مهم جدا بكره القدم الحديثه
يعني باخر عشرين سنه تقريبا اصبح المال
عامل مهم جدا للانتقال اي لاعب ومن زمان
المال المهم ولكن كان في عوامل اخرى ايضا
بنفس الاهميه بس مؤخرا صار هو اهم شيء
لذلك
الدوري الانجليزي شفناها اخذت معظم
المواهب واشترت معظم المواهب من الدوري
الاسباني والايطالي والالماني والفرنسي
وغيرهم من الدوريات الاوروبيين لانه مثل
ما كنا بنعرف انه الانديه الانجليزيه هي
اغنى نوادي في اوروبا
ولذلك نجحت بان تستقطب هؤلاء النجوم ونجحت
بان تعمل اقرا اقوى دوري بالعالم وانه
تكون او يكون دوريها الاكثر متابعه اما
بالنسبه لجوردن هندرسون فالانتقال الى
السعوديه لم يكن فقط من اجل المال لانه ما
في لاعب بكون بقمه مجده وبكون عم يحقق
القاب وبكون سعيد بالمكان اللي هو فيه
وبينتقل الى مكان اخر بس من اجل المال على
سبيل المثال اليوم رحنا عند اللي كانت
هداف الدوري الانجليزي الموسم الماضي
واللي يعني سيطر على كل شيء في الموسم
الماضي وجاب دوري ابطال اوروبا والدوري
الانجليزي وكاس الاتحاد وما الى ذلك تعال
قل له راح اعطيك مليارين دولار تعال العب
بالسعوديه هل رح يقبل ويتركم حقه مع
مانشستر سيتي اكيد لا لاعب سعيد لاعب عم
بيجيب القاب لاعب
مقدر بشكل كبير وشعر انه هو النجم الاول
في الفريق الاداره بتعامله منيح الجماهير
بيعاملو منيح والمدرب بعامله بشكل جيد
وبالتالي ما راح يروح لا على السعوديه ولا
على امريكا ولا على اي مكان اخر هو عم
يتعامل بهاي الطريقه بينما الموضوع مختلف
بالنسبه لجوردن لانه هندرسون وحسب حكيو
انه ما كان شاعر انه يورجن كلوب والاداره
والجماهير بدها اياه بالدرجه الكافيه وقال
انه كلوب قال انه هو راضي عن سوق
الانتقالات يعني بما معناه انه هو رضيان
بمن رحل ورضيان بمن اتى وبالتالي هو كان
بده جوردن هندرسون انه يمشي وقال انه وضح
لي بشكل غير مباشر بيئه اللقاءات انه نحن
مش رح تلعب كثير او ما رح نلعبها كثير
الموسم الجاي وبالتالي هاي كان فيها رساله
مبطنه انه لازم تحمل حالك تتوكل على الله
لذلك اللاعب بالنهايه ما راح يكون عم
يختار الرحيل من فريقه بس من اجل الماء
هاي نقطه النقطه الثانيه انه هندرسون
مدرب الاتفاق وهذا امر بساهم بشكل كبير
بانتقال اللاعب من مكان الى اخر لانه لما
يكون عندك مدرب مقدرك وعلاقتك فيه طيبه
فامورك تمام كونه بالنهايه هو مديرك
وجوردن هندرسون رغم كل هذه الاعتبارات
اتهم انه هو راح على فريق سعودي بس لحتى
يجيب مصاري وترك الامجاد مع ليفربول ولكن
بحقيقه الامر يعني هاي النظريه هي نظريه
كثير سطحيه بالتعامل مع فكره انتقالات
اللاعبين نحو امريكا والسعوديه وغيرهم من
الدول لانه بكل صراحه متل ما حكينا ما في
لاعب راح يترك الامجاد وهو بعزه وينتقل
على السعوديه او على امريكا مهما كان
المبلغ مغري نيمار كان عنده مشاكل مع بي
اس جي بنزيما كان خلص مع ريال مدريد وبلش
وانتقد كانت كان خلص مع تشيلسي فابينيو
خلص مع ليفربول هندرسون خلص مع ليفربول
والقائمه تطول ما راح نحط كل اللاعبين
ولكن ما في لاعب الان فيك تذكره موجود
بالسعوديه كان سعيد بالنادي تبعه وهذا
الامر اللي بتعتمد عليه الانديه بالتعاقد
مع اللاعبين واعتقد انه في بعض الانديه
بالسعوديه يعني مثل الاتحاد وغيرهم او
الانديه المحتاجه اجنحه والاتحاد والاكثر
حاجه لجناح ممكن يفكر بالتعاقد مع لاعب
مثل
ويستغل مشكله او الخلافه اللي صاير بين
اللاعب وبين تنهاج ويجيبوا بمبلغ مرتب وهو
بيعرف كثير منيح انه سوق الانتقالات سكر
وبالتالي ما في لاعب راح يروح على
السعوديه وهو مبسوط ولا على امريكا وهو
مبسوط ولا راح ينتقل من نادي على نادي اخر
حتى باوروبا هو مبسوط دائما في اسباب اخرى
اضف الى ذلك في نقطه مهمه جدا لازم نحكي
عنها قبل ما اختم ما في نادي بيشتري لاعب
يعني لما هندرسون بروح على السعوديه ولا
صلاح بروح على السعوديه ولا مش عارفين
بيروح على السعوديه هذا ليس الشراء من
النادي للاعب هذا شراء عقد مع اللاعب شراء
عقد اللاعب اللاعب في قيمه لعقده بيشتريه
النادي بيدفع له مبلغ معين وبيوظفه كموظف
طبيعي له حقوقه له احترامه له تقدي له له
واجهتوا التسويقيه وله حريه الرحيل عن هذا
النادي عندما يشاء بالشروط الموجوده
بالعقد وبالتالي دائما لما بنحكي بطريقه
انه والله هذا اللاعب او هذا النادي اشترى
هذا اللاعب فهي يعني تعبير غير صحيح
والنظره او السياق او الاصطلاح اللي
بيستخدم فيه ايضا غير صحيح لانه هاي عمليه
تعاقديه مثل ما انت اليوم موظف بشركه
فلانيه باي مجال لما يجيك عرض افضل من
شركه ثانيه راح تنتقل عليها بشكل طبيعي
لانه راح يكونوا اشتروا عقدك ما اشتروك
انت
هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه لون بعض الصافره حتى
نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل